Nabilla malheureusement du prendre un
vol commercial pour entrer de vacances à
Dubaï la peau et elle a si tu as les
alors à votre avis pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle est heureuse mal vu ton
effectivement normalement c'est là c'est
même pas que les les valises doivent pas
dépasser 32 kg quand on a ce qu'on
appelle du or gabarit il faut préciser
prendre un avion cargo le préciser ce
qu'elle a pas dû faire vol commercial
parce que j'avais 15 valises donc
forcément j'avais pas le choix j'ai
toutes mes valises qui faisaient plus de
32 kg j'avais oublié la règle des 32 kg
du coup on a du tout rouvrir acheter une
valise à l'aéroport re-remplir faire des
calculs elle a dit cette phrase et c'est
cette phrase qui a choqué tout le monde
et peut-être était-elle en colère
écoutez-moi bien plus jamais je ne
prendrai de vol d'avion normaux de vol
commerciaux donc
on en est où là alors ces proportionnel
à ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle gagne c'est
son mode de vie elle avait tous ses
enfants et c'est en train de dire
moi je pense que là on l'a perdu
honnêtement parce que c'est une fille
qui avait quand même les pieds ancrés
dans la réalité autrefois moi je l'adore
je l'aime vraiment